نعم الحكايه كبيره بالنسبه لادمان
المراهقين على الريز لكن لماذا تتهم منصات
التواصل بانها السبب نحو 60% من الشباب
يدمنون على ريلز منصات التواصل لمده تصل
لثلاث ساعات يوميا ثم يشعرون بالذنب
والحزن لضياع الوقت جميع منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي مصممه اساسا لابقاء المستخدمين
على اتصال دائم بها نظرا للميزات التي
تجذب مشتركيها استراتيجيات هذه المنصات
تستهدف الجيل بين 8 الى 23 سنه وتنجح
بالتاثير عليهم بشكل كبير فضلا عن تاثيرها
الكبير على مدى تركيزهم وانتباههم خبراء
صحيون اكدوا ان سبب هذا الادمان ان الشباب
يهربون من العالم الحقيقي الى عالم
افتراضيا حالا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات